c'est du sud pour elle pour nous mais il
faut rester positif dans le sort c'est
au moins pu la voir à travers la fin
c'est pas comme l'a fait les manouvres
sa première fois depuis un boulot que
complète à l'extérieur tous les deux
nous accueillent s'apprécie ça faisait
depuis début mars la et pascal j'ai
rencontré un petit garçon bien spéciale
qui a préparé imaginer une centaine de
cartes pour la fête des mères un beau
projet qui a fait sourire beaucoup de
dames aujourd'hui cher mario nous
sautons émerveillé journée de fête des
mères prenez bien soin de vous me gâte
rien
il ya quelques semaines louis gabriel
s'est donné une mission préparer 95
carte de la fête des mères toutes
personnalisées pour chacune des dames
qui habite la résidence pour aînés
l'étincelle et être moins ils vont être
très contente de savoir que l'enfant qui
pensaient les choses de la fête des
mères louis gabriel n'a que 10 ans mais
il a déjà des liens très forts avec la
résidence l'étincelle son grand paris
habité quelques années et il venait de
visiter au moins deux fois par semaine
au début du confinement aussi dit que
peut-être qu'on pourrait en faire des
dessins parole pour les résidents parce
que je me suis dit que ça devait quand
même difficile pour eux d'être isolé
puis il a eu l'idée des cartes
il a demandé à sa grand-mère une artiste
peintre de les dessiner lui se
chargerait de les colorer et d'écrire à
l'intérieur dans mon confinement et ma
solitude ça a été vraiment
ça m'a fait grand bien au moral de
pouvoir participer de plus me sentir
inutile et et ma persévérance
tellement d'ailleurs dans ce projet là
tous les jours il fait de ces cartes
étaient heureux connaît le nom de toutes
les résidentes parker puis attend juste
le moment où on puisse y aller pour les
rencontres et pauvres est alors jouer du
piano ou jouer à des jeux
la première 6 210 cas ça c'est le prix
beau geste tout le temps qu'ils ont mis
à part solo s'il voudrait
pour chacune des mamans qui ont reçu un
grand soutien
il semble que louis gabriel a visé juste
ces cartes ont suscité bien des sourires
chez sa maman et ses grands mamans qui
ont vécu une fête des mères moins
joyeuse qu'à l'habitude il se marie
claude morin radio canada s'intéresse